[Music]
Runk hey guys I will be in Pittsburgh
Pennsyvania tonight October 19th Chris
lea.com at the Bam Theater bam Byam I
don't know uh Byam Byam by him whatever
uh Cleveland Ohio tomorrow October 20th
Detroit Michigan October 21st and then
I'll be in Long Beach California
November second at the Laugh Factory
there doing one night there Orlando
Florida Fort Meers Richmond Virginia
Baltimore Maryland
and Trenton New Jersey you got a bunch
of different uh um Spots I'm doing go to
Chris lead.com to get tickets and uh
also go cap that merch we got merch up
in the man I was just wearing the
actually I was just wearing the uh don't
push me shirt today it was long sleeves
and it's about 85 degrees in Los Angeles
so I had to take it off and just bear my
chest out there and just look crazy into
it um but yeah it was uh it was crazy in
the parking lot I had to I had to take
off my shirt uh and and and and just go
crazy bear chested and then put on that
don't push me over over my chest and
just everybody knew I meant business and
then also uh we got the life rips decals
for the cars and and uh the pockets stay
deep uh hoodie and for the winter and
then also um the uh the Winter Wear
which is the um the flannels that join
the cult flannels and the grower dye
hoodies oh it looks so ridiculously
amazing and then the life rips favorites
and the new colorways go to crystal.com
and besides that let's get into it this
is everyone's favorite podcast on
religion
[Music]
congratulations
conat honestly this is how it looks now
I feel like I didn't so I don't have the
uh headphones on um and I cu the reason
is cuz I just got out of shower because
I wanted to be clean and nice for you
guys and uh I you know I wash my hair
because I do that I know that people
think I don't wash my hair because uh I
look greasy and that's not my Pro that's
my fault it's my problem but not my
fault I don't look GRE I don't I'm not
greasy uh every woman I've ever been
with anybody who's ever been close to me
they would be like oh you know what you
actually smell terrific and you're
really clean so a lot of people think
I'm greasy though CU I have this look
and that's fine dude I get it I have
like a you know a salt and pepper beard
and my hair looks wet because I put
Pomade in it by the way
dorks people are like oh he's got dude
I'm just cool with the Pomade man think
of The Fawns right like that's kind of
how I am so uh anyway starting off real
defensive like but so I don't have the
these on right because my hair's drying
and it's wet and this is how I look when
I get out of the shower and I I feel
like I wish I kind of just remained
looking like this but my hair gets a
little bit puffed forward sometimes like
a German at the end of the movie like at
the end of a James Bond movie like he's
fighting and going down in a [__] big
plane with James Bond in it and he's
just like we were boss die I guess Mr
Bond
and uh with the like the the poofed up
hair cuz it's not perfect cuz they've
been fighting and then 007 jumps out
with a parachute
planet
[Music]
planet and then uh the German dies in
the plane
[Music]
planet planet
planet is that James Bon or's that Miss
possible I always mix him up whatever um
any I did Jim hell yeah dude hell yeah
he knows what's up
uh yeah it's been a lot going on in the
world a lot of people want respon I'm
going to put these on actually a lot of
people want responses and stuff and uh
declarations and and uh not declarations
but
uh who do you stand with and it's just
like dude I don't I I'm a comedian I'm
such an idiot I just like let me just be
silly how about that come to me for
Relief uh I know nothing about what's
going on period only thing I really know
about are like you know pants and chicks
uh and uh my life my life my life my
life my life ducking one
time um and I don't even read the news
dude I I I'm on this new thing where I
just don't read the news and new it's
been the past few hours I mean few years
hours wow I don't read the news dude it
just makes me sad and so I'm now I'm not
sad but
uh there's certain things you can't
avoid right even if you don't read the
new news like
uh by the way I uh oh well actually no I
don't know if there's something you
could avoid or not but
uh Michael Kane retired he retired from
he finally he finally said I won't do it
he finally said it a script came the I
wonder what script just made him be like
all right never mind or if it was not
even if it was a movie set and he just
goes like this can't do it anymore
imagine your the the set you're on is
the last one Michael Kane's on how like
and have him be like like you know that
a little bit it's your fault he retired
I know he's 90 and he should have
retired already cuz what not I mean not
that he should have retired because he's
not good he's still
great but uh he literally is the last
movie he did is the last movie he did
and that was the set that you on as a
director or whatever a gaffer other
actors that was the experience the guy
will not turn down anything
dude the guy won't turn down for what
and that last set he's on he just goes
like this you know what I'm not doing it
anymore no no no I won't do it anymore
and he had like one last bagel from
Craft service and he just goes like this
this is the last
time he's 90 dude it's crazy how long
he's been 92 as well it's been at least
I and I don't mean he's because he's
always looked older but he's been 90 for
at least seven years it's crazy like you
know when you see somebody finally and
you're like oh [__] they got old like K
Reeves in the bill and teds movie like
it wasn't like John Wick he still looked
Dume and then he shaved the beard did
Bill and Ted and you go like this oh
[__]
right some people just keep looking
fantastic like Hugh Jackman the guy
dropped his wife and just looks better
dude it's
crazy it's crazy dude Hugh Jackman goes
like this yeah I want to divorce and
then it and just his face cleared
up uh heart goes out to Hugh Jackman and
his wife or whatever because I I [__]
love him man I hope he's doing well and
he just posted more on Instagram just
being all single and [__] Hugh Jackman
man guy looks fantastic it's [__] up
how good he looks he gets better looking
some people just they age very very well
you
know I got bags under my eyes but still
I go to the gym I [__] kill it man
sweating like a mad man but um but yeah
dude uh what do you call it Hugh Jackman
looks amazing there was papar dude there
were Paparazzi there was Paparazzi video
of Hugh Jackman the other day on
Instagram and I'm not bullshitting I
watched it six times in a row I'm not
even bullshitting and I'm just admitting
that right now like I didn't even
realize I did that till now six times in
a row he just hey how's it going and it
was
like Hey Mr Jackman how you doing I'm
doing all
right it's not it's that trt maybe I
don't know I was Googling trt the other
day and my wife came looked over my
shoulder and she was like No And I say
I'm not I'm not saying I'm getting it
I'm just
saying you want you know you want I'm 43
right I'm still young I'm still crazy
young right
but you want me still you want me St you
want you know what I'm saying like Hugh
Jackman's what he's 50 something you
want me
stacked you want me crazy with the show
that go on for days put a week on it
what you want dude you want it to look
like I'm always I got a backpack on I
mean what do you want what's going on
right you want to look like I got a vest
on under my shirt like what's the deal
because this goes away the
testosterone trt you keep doubling
it you're looking great dude I need to
get on that trt and just just [__]
just now you know what I need to get on
steroids for real I know I've said this
before but just crazy with the mid just
a crazy Gap in between my
teeth to where I when I talk you see my
tongue flick out of it like I'm a lizard
like my Michael strayan like the white
Michael
strayan just big shoulders a such it's
the the gap between my teeth is so big
you could buy a cable knit sweater in it
like that's how big it is just so
insanely just just goofed out just the
the right tooth don't want nothing to do
with the left tooth
dude you know what I'm talking
about that would be just gangster to
just start doing steroids now my wife
won't let me she says no you'll get too
horny I go I go all right if that's what
you all right then with did shoulders
suffer and so does the
boinkin
right I got a buddy who's like man had a
chick over last night had sex with her
hour and a half and I tell him she
doesn't want that dude and he says no
not the way I do it like he viciously
believes that he's right and you know
the the the girl is just the whole time
just like in her head just like my God
this is
long but she's still got to be like yeah
yeah oh yeah you know and he's just
working away she doesn't want it he
probably doesn't even want it either you
know he's just like sweating so hard on
his couch in his one
bedroom dude an out we had and he'll
still tell me this i' for years I've
been telling them dude she does they
don't want that an hour
dude you're exhausted at the end of it I
know we've talked about this early early
on in the congratulations archives the
top time to have sex is 12 minutes dude
that's the top amount of time the peak
most enjoyable
shits or let
less sometimes 12 is too long busting
six and a
half it's just crazy dude dudes think
like nah man I'm going to turn her out
my favorite of the guys that like you
know this has happened where they're
just like dude I'm G to Fu like my
favorite is a guy that like thinking you
know how like everything's happened in
the world everything in the world has
happened because it's just like been
around for so
long like there like I love thinking
about a guy being like baby I'm going to
[__] you all night and she's like okay
and he's like hell yeah all night here
we go and just slides in and
just just can't even hold it at all and
just absolutely explodes
immediately ah sweet I'm going to [__]
you all night oh yeah yep here we
go oh
[Music]
God and he impregnates her and it's just
a [__] the worst life later you know
they don't even like each
other yeah how's that for [__] all
night huh give me a heads up next time
you splurt it inside and now we've got a
kid that won't talk to me and I hate
you all from a dude just thinking he's
gonna rock it oh dude I'm gonna rock
it when I have sex I rock it dude not me
I'm not good at it not me I'm not good
at it at all but that's what makes me
good at it you can't care too much dude
he truly can't my buddy cares too much
and I just know he's not good I know not
good part of me wants to shift into a
woman to see just to see what it's like
right cuz I could have him do my butt
but not really though because it's
different man I'm not into it but if I
was a woman I'd be into it I really want
to see what he's like dude how how dope
would that be if you were a woman you
could just test out some men without
being gay just seeing what's up just
rank them you know what in the text chat
light it up you know just I got I got a
text chat with five dudes in there they
all think they're Alphas dude let me
just shift into a lady and just just
absolutely laid down for all of them and
then then come back as a man and rank
them all dude the roast sessions would
be insane do you know what I'm talking
about oh yeah you [__] for an hour
dude you should do it for two minutes
that's how bad it was do you know what
I'm
[Music]
saying just
like I don't know what do you think
women down there I want to see the
comments even though I won't look what
how how long is the best amount for sex
argue with yourselves I say 12 minutes I
say 7 to 12 minutes ah 7 Minutes kind of
short
honestly 12 minutes I say I've always
said 12 minutes at 4:30 p.m. with the
[__] leaf blower going off in the
background no music my wife goes like
this can we ever start playing music
when when we have sex and I go I say if
you want like what do you want to play
the weekend or some [__] you
know what do you
play the weekend like what do you play
when you [__] what are you supposed to
do put on Phil Collins what One More
Night One More Night
[Music]
oo that's a problem though if you got
the iPod Shuffle or whatever on and then
you play it and it's just like one more
night and then [__] Lean Back comes
on and you're like all right the whole
mood changed never
mind or some jiss starts you know or or
even worse like the [__] comedy album
that from Mitch fatel that you
downloaded in
2008 um but yeah dude it's just uh I
don't know man stop trying so hard I
guess but uh Michael Kane's retired is
what I'm trying to say a lot of stuff
going on with famous people Jason Mamoa
dressed like Johnny Depp apparently uh
what's her name the crazy one uh amber
herd said that she was had suffering
from PTSD because um Jason M MOA
purposely dressed up as Johnny Depp to
play a prank on her in
um Aquaman whatever movie it is and it's
like oh by the way there's a I found out
in Aquaman there's a a baby in it like
they had a baby and the name is aqua
baby hey try harder you
know Aqua
baby uh
um but Mamoa was dressing she was like
he's dressing up like Johnny Depp too
much as a prank and it was her PTSD her
fake PTSD because obviously she's lying
but
um hey how about this dude hey here's
why that's [__] you ever seen Jason
Mamoa he looks like he shares a closet
with Johnny Depp he dresses like Johnny
Depp if Jason Mamoa dressed like Johnny
Depp this is what everyone else thinks
oh [__] it's Jason
Mamoa he he dresses the same they both
have long hair they wear dumb hats and
like a stupid [__] outfit that's like
two beay or some [__] with no shirt
underneath and 48
bracelets what do you mean that's like
being like oh dude you
know crystalia dresses like [__] I
don't
know that's being like Jeremy rener
dresses like [__] Oliver Hudson what the
[__] why is he doing that they just wear
shirts and jeans
dude Jason Mamoa looks like Johnny Depp
got a got a tan and put the mask
on that Jim Carrey
won smok
him he just is like a beefed up Johnny
Depp on
vacation what are you talking about he
dressed like Johnny
Depp
that's so insane dude and everyone has
to be like oh okay you're PTSD oh man
what were we at
War
whatever any anybody who wears hats
really just too many hat anything
besides a baseball hat I don't give a
[__] anything besides a baseball hat
you're just you're you're trying fedora
bowler's hat anything that that [__]
football player wears Cam Newton the
high ass hat looks like it has a cake in
it um so anyway I'm team uh
Mamoa dude I remember my mom used to
start she never drank really until like
we got we're like in our 20s she just
started drinking mimosas dude I love how
it was just too much for her it was too
much to like when a mosa came out dude
when the mimosas started getting [__]
out there oh are you kidding just
Housewives they go like this what's in
it oh my leaves or whatever the [__]
in it you know oh it looks like dirty
dishwater with [__] parsley in
it
ooh yeah mimosas that's what they look
like well that's what my mom did it
that's what that's how my mom had it I
mean look
Mimosa she she put the [__] in
it
mosha I'm not talking about mosha what
am I talking about
Mo that's what it is dude
Mo even better dude Mo
Mojitos oh [__] dude wow wow wow that
made me oh Mojitos
dude my mom saw a Mojito and she goes
wait a minute just so much [__] in it
looks like [__] dishw water just
[__] strawberries and parsley in it
just something my son would make and be
like Dad I made a potion and old house
ladies Housewives were just like ooh
just like dude here's what a Mojito
looks like strawberries parsley and then
Dawn dish soap dipped in just disgusting
hey it's dirty send it just a full lime
in it just a whole bundle of grapes just
in it you know not taking off the stems
in it ah move this [__] out of the way
Mojitos dude my mom would be like I love
Mojitos they're just too refreshing dude
she couldn't help it she didn't drink
forever and she saw mojito and [__]
caved
bro what's in a Mojito let's look isn't
it crazy that some food is so good and
compliments each other but then you
can't make a [__]
like I was eating great Mexican food the
other night just really good it's called
joselitos which sounds like a fake
madeup amalgamation of a Mexican name
but it was in Lin and it's called
joselitos and it was so good dude rice
and beans M that's it for you just
chicken enchiladas M that's it for you
just beef burritos M that's it for you
chicken tacos with the guacamole on it m
that's it for you dude I loved it man
but I also love chocolate and you can't
put that on there you know shout out to
the chefs that [__] figured out what
compliments each other
honestly
really being real because my boy let me
tell you something I got I order ordered
from Amazon Lulu Gonzalez the person who
features for me on the road fantastic
comedian she told me about protein
pancakes and I go like this I'm not a
guy who's like big on like hey dude got
to eat protein you know but she's like
get protein pancakes they're really good
and I said how good could they be so I
go on Amazon what the [__] what the hell
I got to lose I look up protein pancakes
I get protein pancakes I get a box of
protein
pancakes it's however much it is I don't
know how much it is I don't look at
price and then it shows up the next day
oops got six boxes so I have so many
[__] Kodiak bear protein pancakes I
made them this morning for me and Calvin
dude I [__] house them up by the way
breakfast is a scam all good not talking
about it done breakfast is a scam you
don't need to eat right away Kellogg he
got us didn't he oh it just got me oh
the DI of that just got me Kellogg made
it up dude to sell corn flakes good job
man the Hallmark of [__] meals we
don't need it Hallmark that [__] shop
you go in and get cards Hallmark
holidays
Jesus Hallmark run by Nazis but just
like anyway what I'm saying is you don't
need to eat breakfast eat wake up if you
wake up you're hungry eat but dude you
know how many times I've woken up hungry
in my life let me tell you right
now I'm not lying twice
twice one time when I was living in
Burbank and once recently two different
times and I've been eatting breakfast my
whole life that's a lie wake up do what
I it takes so long to figure out what
you want to do it really does it takes
so long to figure out what you want to
do and who you are deep inside of you
took me 40 [__] years
man I was born to be a dad and don't
want breakfast dude and that's it is
this boring I don't give a [__] man you
know it's my diary at this point I love
you guys for listening man for
real oh
god oh how about the [__]
uh yo let me ask a question
man J pinket
sup hey Jada pinket
sup hey hey hey Will Smith by the way
worked with you both met Jada once met
Will Smith maybe twice dude what's going
on hey guys how about this stop talking
right it only gets worse Will Smith does
anybody see a picture of Will Smith now
and go oh yeah yeah that slap
changed everything in that man's life
when he smacked Chris
Rock it [__]
everything
up and then J
pinket on her book why is she writing
the
book you got hun
Mals dude I don't get the mindset more
more more more more I do when it comes
to sex whoopsy Daisy when I was 38
whoopsy okay but I don't get the more
more more I want more more more I need
to I want to write a book who writes a
dude here's who should write a book a
bookwriter a
writer writing writers they must lose
their [__] minds they must lose their
minds when actors are like you know what
it's time to tell my story
no it's
not I mean I guess it is if you have a
big enough fan base make that money and
I'm joking this is a comedy podcast but
holy [__] [__]
dude why for what for what $5 million
you got it for what 10 Milli you got it
you could take Chopper rides to the
grocery store you got it you're
done for what you'll never catch me
writing a book unless this is a silly
creative one you'll never catch me an
auto by that by the way you didn't even
write someone else
did some white older Jewish guy wrote it
you
know just stop talking stop the red
table nonsense just you know it's just
I'm it's too lucrative I I don't
actually mean stop but it's like the
[__] you say it's all coming back
now and Jade is just like I I haven't
even been married to Will Smith for
seven years just saying [__] Tupac
Shakur was my soulmate I mean what
dude imagine Kristen said someone else
was their soulmate I'd go like
this you this me picture me Kristen said
someone else I'm I'm that [__] white
blonde dude in the
meme just I'm I'm I'm that old dude
that's like
this who's that old dude that the
Swedish dude the [__] really big meme
that oh I can't
even I don't know you think you have
more than one soulmate though maybe
maybe you have more than one soulmates
who knows that there no such thing as a
soulmate right anyway um but yeah dude I
just keep they just keep digging dude
and I I bet they're good people too you
know I bet they're good
people they're so sweet uh uh Jaden is
the sweetest [__] I bet they're
all really good people man and we don't
know and we're all just like oh yeah the
people talking about how this is what
happens when you marry a you know you
don't
know but uh crazy how uh how that
happens just one slap they're going to
make a documentary you know they're
going to make a documentary about that
they're going to call it the
slap and it's going to come out next
year and it's going to be like just
crazy in depth and I won't watch it
there's I mean there's no way in [__]
hell I'll watch it although I didn't
think I'd watch that Beckham one and my
wife W my wife was watching and she was
like I just knew that this was going to
happen dude I hear so here's the deal
I'm in the upstairs room and I just
hear and I'm like oh
no I'm too smart to know she's not I
know she's not watching Arsenal I know
she's not watching soccer games I don't
know if it's soccer season or not but I
know she's not watching soccer games I
know she's not number one because she
doesn't watch soccer games and number
two because it's not 3:00 a.m. right
because that's when soccer games are on
it was in the afternoon so I go like
this she's watching that goddamn David
documentary isn't she I walk down sure
enough there that handsome [__]
is and it's when I I'm married I would
dve 6 I was just a hang at with her for
10 minutes and six hours back just so in
love with posw spice or whatever her
name was and now I got a [__] you
know by the way Beckham is ruining it
for every other dude out there the guy's
a billionaire and he's literally on
camera being like yeah we'll draw like 4
hours to see it for like 20 minutes and
then draw a bit and then i' go on a play
then i' go want to play our rivals or
going to play
Argentina and I I here I am just some
guy that's
like oh I'm tired from my
shows will you please let me sleep
in David Beckham's like any chance I get
I'd like to see my wife it doesn't
matter I don't even sleep I have those
little Clockwork Orange [__] things
that keep my eyes open remember when
they were watching all those [__]
visions of the world blowing up remember
when they did tests on them I sleep with
those open and just sit in a chair and
watch watch
sleep and I'm like at [__] 10:30 can
I sleep more I had two shows last night
in
Cina oh he chared a jet to have lunch
with her I know he's Rich right but
like yeah one I just can't get a [__]
jet come down have a little Ving boy to
in floor back in New Circle and
win making us all look bad and handsome
as [__] the dude a 10 walking around in
whatever clothes he wants he used to
wear a song just killing
it guy gets better looking too for
[__] sake whatever dude me too but
it's crazy so I'm like oh she's watching
the [__] dark God damn it dude now I
got to watch it here's the other thing
about it I know I know I'm G to like
it I don't want to watch something that
I'm going to like you know what I'm
saying I don't want to get into
something
that I that is about something that I
don't care
about why can't I just not care about
something and not change that right oh
you're gonna make me watch an in-depth
documentary about David Beckham someone
that I don't care about doing a job that
I don't care about and now I'm all
involved watching it like did somebody
make popcorn what are we doing let's
nosh
I'm listening to David Beckham's coach
like oh he's got a good point like I
don't give a [__] but now I
do oh see they're treating him unfairly
like I'm doing that kind of [__]
watching the
thing and then I had to go I had to
drive to Cina to do my shows
right all sold out they love the kid
whatever then I I [__] dude now I got
to wake up the next morning and she's
like I watch it again you got to watch
the end part you're going to love it and
I and I know I am but I don't want to
dude you know what I'm
saying just let me be a Cragin dude let
me be a sleepy
Cragin I like coffee I like making
jokes and driving to no music those are
the three things I
like so it's like
she's like her friends were so loyal and
you would love that I would I would
she's right I would dude apparently when
the world was hating on him dude he
couldn't go out without getting [__]
accosted apparently his friends were
still in his corner and she said I would
love it and she's right I would I
would [__] David Becka man you got a
fan in me dude but you're making it hard
for everyone else who's married so stop
talking about how much you love your
wife and you drive [__] hours to her
to see her for 20 minutes anyway scream
Gigi by up this is not an ad go to my
page if you want to purchase a 10-word
ad or shout out holler. christalia if
you're a nurse in Connecticut come work
for the best agency visit
www.pro prom medstaff c.com to apply go
to my page if you want to purchase a
10-word ad or shout out holler.
christalia um yeah I got good nurses or
something in Connecticut or whatever in
that [__] hole Connecticut dude sh
Connecticut the audiences the audiences
are are such a mix of [__] up because
they're the high futin rich people and
then the drunk ass bluecollar
[__] when you play for them
they either think oh we deserve this or
they're [__] Rowdy and got to kick
them
out
what is this uh oh my God Biden campaign
joins truth
social well let's see how this goes
converts
welcome Crazy Eight 385 likes you
know nobody's going to like it wow I
wonder what people said under it truth
social is
um um uh what's what's uh Trump's
Twitter right mhm yeah dial pad has
completely transformed too loud and it's
also annoying that it's a [__] ad God
damn
it I H why do I always have to sign in
this is the bane of my existence dude I
always have to sign
in lady kills it what's this outfit that
ladies wear you
know what she
holding a [__] twisty
a Mastadon
[Music]
tus yeah yeah yeah oh so
Pennsylvania this whole thing this is if
you found the middle of Pennsylvania
like if you found if you mathematically
found the middle of Pennsylvania this is
it right here this lady standing there
with a Mastadon Tusk and this
outfit that all [__] counselors in
high school
wear second time exclusive here at Gard
Park cat karaoke Missy's funky white
sister is in the
park in the park
[Music]
dude No Nonsense at all is it let me
work it I put my thing now flip it and
reverse it
your
your got a big let me search
you if you got a big let me search you
dude so no nonsense dude this is
unbelievable man holy [__] the short
hair and the [__] Mumu you know just
killing it find out how hard I got to
[Music]
work dude imagine like making love with
this woman just uh oh oh oh it would be
like that the whole time I like to get
to
know
like told you oh beat the [__] up she
said 60m give me all your numers so I
can phone you you girl then call me over
let me ask a question why is everybody
at the park not losing their [__]
they're just like having a picnic and
stuff he's like yeah so anyway I talked
to Jake the other day did you hear it
yeah no so he's going to be out of
commission for a while he broke he broke
he broke his foot yeah yeah so in the
meantime you got [__] you know a
principal just it's ner
on the bed lay me on your s come before
you come I need to S my you do or you
don't or you
well like a see my hips and my chips
don't see my ass and my lips don't I
lost few pounds in my whips for you this
kind of be could
go he me to say blah blah blah work it I
need a glass of water boy oh boy it's
good to know Y is it work let me work p
my thing now
F dude
incredible
incredible oh I I I I I I just saw a
thing I got to click on sorry guys just
nothing I would like nothing I would
like more than this so sorry guys but
bodybuilder shocked by rapping Uber
driver sorry
guys come on get to
it let's see let's see let's see
bored um so uh I don't like when people
rap that aren't from the streets sorry
there I said it I do no take that back
it's fine but don't be like
hey
dude yeah don't be like that dude it's
okay if you rap but do it like that lady
did you
know but don't be like H he yeah okay
yeah yeah oh God that's cringe dude when
you're just a guy you know how about
when Drake did this
though how about when Drake did this
hold on let me get it let me get it let
me get it let me get it h on let me get
it
combin yeah dude so
Jamaican we love it dude
combination That's crazy dude let's play
it again I got on my phone I think or my
computer I think combination oh
dude
combination how come people just let him
get away with it he's so good though
he's just so
good Jada pinket says that Tupac was his
her soulmate that's crazy I mean I mean
Will Smith must just be like like
so
mad I saw the funniest meme though it
was
like what was it Jada pinket with
Tupac now that
um now that Will Smith left and it just
showed a it it was Lady in bed and she
her mouth was open and it was like
this it was so stupid why would uh Jada
pinket say they were living completely
separate lives since
2016 uh when she talked to on the when
she did the um
interview pinkit Smith was asked about
Shakur who died after being gunned down
in 1996 being her soulmate she agreed
and discussed this strong
connection ah you know maybe Will Smith
is I don't know I don't we don't know
let's stop you know let's just
stop
um the uh Dylan danis and Logan Paul
ball fight happened and it was crazy the
uh entertainment boxing is wild I I I
think first of
all those Paul brothers are good they
really are taking it seriously and
they're really good you
can't look I'm not a boxer I don't know
the technical [__] about it all and I
done it for a few years now but they
train really hard they obviously have
the best uh you know people uh involved
helping to have them train because they
have they have the money they certainly
have the money but
like that whole thing was making me so
sad up until the fight because they the
the the Nina is it gdal Nina something
was dragged into it and you know she's
probably sweeter than [__] I don't know
her at all but
um man that that was a wild thing are
they going to sue him are they goingon
to they said they might sue him sha says
there's no suing in boxing but I don't
know or in fighting but I don't know
they might do
it um check this out I got this page uh
go to my page if you want to purchase a
10-word ad or shout out holler. bab
christalia and this is a good one if you
like chubby ebony women www.
onlyfans.com Molly thee worker if you
like chubby ebony women hell yeah dude
that deserves one of these where is it
where is it great pissed where is it
here it
is it's always too low dude there we go
hell yeah dude um I'm back went to went
to go to the bathroom Sorry by the way
how often do you guys go to the bathroom
I go to the bathroom
once
every hour and a half is that too much
do I have a problem how many times are
you supposed to pee a day if you're a
man how many many
times
urinate spelled it completely wrong Nate
a day is normal is it different for a
man or what six and seven
times uh most people the normal number
of times to your per day is between 6
and 7 and a 24-hour period between four
and 10 times a day can also be normal if
that person is healthy and happy with
the number of times so 10 okay I I guess
I probably do that I have to
count is it normal to urinate every two
hours thises is about women hold on from
how many times
do men urinate a day okay uh okay every
two hours for a men for the most part
six to eight times is The Sweet Spot
and a day six times no way dude I drink
too much coffee that's probably the
thing coffee and water that's it that's
all I
drink uh top reasons you're peeing so
much here we go I really sorry guys I
really want to look at this here uh if
you're hitting the bathroom every hour
so so your bladder might be trying to
tell you something okay here we
go more than once a night I don't do it
more than once a night so that's good oh
you have to pay for this article oh eat
my [__] absolutely eat my [__]
never mind dude paying for news is crazy
it's I mean I guess that's not really
news that's just an article that what's
it called did so all
good
um goated Riz buson simp and more added
to the Webster dictionary finally dude
Riz just came out how did they bson been
around s been around goated been around
Riz I feel like is like I just heard it
they really worked Riz was the one where
they were like okay I guess we got to
update it there's too
many RZ came one more and we updated and
it's Riz
um I can't believe
though they really got the Miriam
Webster really got the corner market on
that [__] dictionary huh
you can get a different one but I mean
it's just the same word so I guess it
doesn't matter 690 new words have been
added to the w wow dude Riz goated busen
simp let's see what else um these okay
um okay yeah a lot of them are digital
words because obviously that is growing
oh wow they they
added Nerf cutscene Rage
Quit and thirst trap grammable ew an
edge
Lord what is Edge Lord let me look it
up it's like a
what I'm looking it up Edge Lord a
person who affects a provocative or
extreme Persona especially online
typically used of a man Edge Lords act
like contrarians in the hope that
everyone will admire them as Rebels oh
like a lord of the edge I thought it was
like when somebody's like trying to like
wait make you come after like hours and
hours just teasing you I'm the edge Lord
I'll make you want to come for over six
hours I'm the edge
Lord where is thou fulum
gland where is thou where is th frenulum
gland let's see it Belly Up hey Edge
Lorden what are you doing Edge
Lorden oh my Edge Lord
dude uh signs of a healthy language
include words being created words being
borrowed from other languages and new
meanings being given to the existing
words that's what somebody said here in
a quote on hype Beast
um yeah well I guess they're going to
have to go into a does anyone have a
dictionary or do they just look it up I
I never used a dictionary in my life
remember when [__] your mom would be
like if you don't know how to spell it
look it up in the dictionary and it's
like I I don't know how to [__] spell
it how do I look it up I need to know
how to spell it to [__] look it up
but you know the first letter and then
you go to the second letter and it's
it's it's quite annoying though because
they got you you
know this Lenny Kravitz is taking us to
the stratosphere here Lenny kravit shows
off his huge guitar and thirst heavy so
Lenny Kravitz the worst actor is uh and
I say that only because he's in the
movie [__] I always forget the name
mocking jay what is
it what is it Hunger
Games uh the actor musician looks
mind-blowingly hot for 59 years of age
dude it's crazy he's 60 the guy's got a
[__] six pack and E60 they're
probably airbrushing it a little bit but
this week Kravitz announced 12 studio
album blue electric light with release
date set for 2004 okay
so God he's 60 bro a full head of
beautiful hair remember when his [__]
fell out when he was doing the [__]
when he did splits and his [__] fell out
um so this is the new music video for
him oh
yeah right here does he have I guess we
can't play this song but I I'll go
on I'll go on uh what do you call it
mute but um he has a big ass guitar and
I'm I'm I'm going on I'm going out on
the ledge here it's it's symbolic of his
penis am I right or what
um here we go he's waking up in bed dude
he's
69 this is CRA what does he eat just
live chickens
That's crazy dude make it be have your
dick out I want it to have everything
dude bro this is it's unfair how good
black people look when they get older
it's
crazy there's this butt why wouldn't he
do this good for him
man my
God this is
like
he's got to be so annoying
right dude he's
ripped what's going on
Jesus this guy's the uh a dream guy
ah dude 59
bro this is crazy dude
I'm 43 and I look like dog [__] compared
to this
guy my God I got to get my [__] [__]
up dude I got to start eating better
that's what I got to do I still eat good
dude I ate a [__] last night I
cracked didn't I I did my parents got
Mexican food and I cracked is there any
good for you Mexican food or is it all
just mixed up [__] one way or another
rice Bean
[__] guacamole it's all the same [__]
tacos nachos burritos it's all the same
there's no good for you Mexican
foods um but yeah dude I got to eat I
got to eat good except for the fact that
man it's hard you know when the pretzels
are around and the cookies they they're
around dude ah
[__] God damn it the cookies are around
and I ate them and that's such a
beautiful thing to say but I really did
I if they're around I'll be eating them
because that's what happens when they're
around you know what I'm talking about
you're chilling you're watching a show I
watched it follows again which by the
way I think it might be a masterpiece I
watched it follows that's a [__]
horror movie about when you [__] someone
and then the person tries to follow you
very slowly until they get you and kill
you and you got to [__] someone else to
break the curse to make sure they get
there they get they get killed and then
if they get killed then it goes back to
you so it's like you got to keep [__]
really which is what it is I'm very into
the movie I like I like [__] and um I
like [__] and I like horror so really
it's great so it's great for me so I
watch the movie by the way I think it's
a masterpiece and if you think that I
watched that [__] movie and then
didn't watch YouTube videos about the
movie you're absolutely insane the only
way to watch a movie right now
especially a horror movie is to watch a
movie and then go to YouTube as soon as
it's over you don't watch the credits
you
go and you click on YouTube and you type
in it follows explained or whatever it
is and that's when you really understand
why you like the movie because they
explained it for you because I'm a
[__] dumbass that's why I go huh that
was a really good movie and then they
explain to me why the director did what
they did and why it was written the way
they did and why the actors did what
they did and why the shots are the way
they were and that's when I go oh yeah
that's why thank you for telling me why
I like this movie because I am a [__]
follower and a plebian but dude that
movie was so good and after I watch
those explains it videos oh my God it
got so much better it's so good it's
about it's about growing up it's about
growing up up and then being scared to
death and and not being able to and
losing the innocence of childhood oh
dude I didn't know it he didn't know it
till he watched it again and watched the
Explains It video but it's a great movie
though it really is man and it's done so
well but then
anyway uh I ate dude I was watching a
guy on Instagram the other day gay but I
was and I was looking at his body gay
but I was and it said what he
eats and I looked at what he eats on the
[__] thing and it had everything he
eats and then it goes like this the guy
was shredded and the guy goes like and
the guy
says this is what I eat B breakfast like
what in the week one cheat meal not Day
meal and I go like this oh never mind
I'll be a fat
guy one cheat
meal [__] dude this is a health and
wellness podcast what what is that what
what does he what does he mean too he
means like sushi oh dude to me that
counts as a good for you
meal you know what a cheat meal is for
me honestly here's what a cheat meal is
for me pizza and then pasta and then ice
cream and a cookie and then later on I
eat also other junk
food that's a cheat
meal I go like this well I had a cheat
meal ah [__] it I'll just go for it
today and tomorrow I'll do
better you got to have your cheat Meals
late in the day otherwise you have a
cheat meal at first in the morning you
go ah the whole day screw [__] it I'll
have a bunch of cheat meals I have a
whole cheat day I have a cheat week [__]
it I'll be a fat guy God damn it
dude got to get them back of the love
handles off in the back
dude got to get those love handles off
in the back but you know what I realized
actually because I was wearing the
[__] underwear and then I was seeing
like a little bit of the stuff peel off
on the side right like a muffin top like
I'm I'm fit like I'm not saying like I
got you know but then I was real I go
like this I look at the size of my
underwear
dude
medium hey medium you know last time I
bought underwear I'm being real with you
over a decade ago I've been wearing
medium underwears I'm 6'2 I weigh 200 lb
I've been wearing medium up medium siiz
underwear for over a DEC I've been
wearing medum do you know how dude I'm
6'2 my waist is 33 I'm [__] crazy big
not to mention I got to fit my [__] all
in there medium dude no wonder it looks
like I got a muffin top my waist is
getting
strangled sometimes when I get a bone
doggy I got to put it up right I got to
put it up it looks like my penis is
getting choked it looks my penis is just
trying to look at what's for dinner you
know what I'm saying it looks my my my
penis oh
dude I'm above the Buckle right put me
down I can't it's too stiff okay well
all right let's chill for a little bit
then don't think
it's let me shrivel up for a bit dude I
I wear medium underwear you know how
dumb that is I haven't bought new
underwear we were talking about the
group I got to get new underwear cuz I
used to wear meundies but they're
[__] cucks over there so I sto I you
know I I still have them but I haven't I
didn't buy
any um and so I didn't so I don't so but
medium how how long long do you wait to
buy new underwear till there's holes or
till there I haven't bought underwear in
my underwear is probably disgusting
granted I've never [__] in my underwear
I'm being for real with that I'm being
for real with
that also how many times you wipe your
butt for no reason and there's [__] in
it all good not me I'm just saying I
know people who do
that let's look at some deserved skilles
oh I'm not going to be able to do
it no wait I am I am we got the
Doritos oh
[__]
that's that that this might be the best
one we've ever had dude with the Doritos
putting the Doritos in the thing oh my
god
dude he puts it in the cup holder then
he takes the thing out under the cup
holder and he can't get it
out oh
[__] the way he says oh [__] oh it's
just so good dude wow that's so
great oh [__] dude oh [__] [__] wait I
got to watch that again dude look at how
look at how crafty he thinks he's being
too what a fat [__] with the Dorito
salsa
too oh
[__] oh [__] dude that guy oh [__] he's
Indian no doubt he's
Indian that's great oh oh that one's
great that's a 10 the best one I ever
seen I think okay got weight
lifting not crazy amount of weight but
oh
Jesus NS
godam oh my God why' he do it so quick
he's going to hurt
himself dude it's not even
that nuts godamn
it how do you even [__] I know how did
he even hit hit your dick with the
barbell like
that oh my [__] nuts oh [__] on my
nuts why I
mean launching a
bucket here we
go broke no dude it hit his head dude
come on dude be faster you [__] broke
it oh be
faster so
unathletic
unathletic playing chicken at that's a
that's a nine that was a nine playing
chicken at the end of a water
slide oh boy
idiot oh no uh another person
right oh oh broke his [__]
nose ooh I hate the guy that came down
second you know did you just watch it
dude dude that's too much of
pain smooth with it in the first guy
though right in his [__] nose dude
you don't have your eyes open guy tried
to oh he [__] him up bro
ooh his nose broke for sure his knee
just went right into his that looked
like a Mortal Kombat
uh
whatever wow that's a seven cuz it
looked like it hurt too bad I don't like
those kinds of things uh all right thank
you very much for listening
[Music]
patreon.com/lenguin
[__]
[Music]